who had been married the longest who'd
we decide
40 years that's fantastic i'm gonna go
the other what's that
they left
kenny hates old people kenny hates old
people
hey are they they left i mean they
married for 40 years you sure they
didn't [ __ ] just you know uh
it is west palm beach he never even
maybe they were cats and they were like
we gotta go die somewhere right now so
okay so
besides those people
who came in second
anybody who who else
how long well 32 years is amazing
congratulations now i'm going to go the
other way and just out of curiosity
who what about some young relationships
no young relationships how how long man
or two years
that's awesome man and so i and so
where'd you guys meet
oh in high school oh okay but the way
you said it you sounded like glory hole
i mean you got
you were so embarrassed you're like oh
god i can't believe we're going to tell
this story
high school is not about
it i was at one of these things
[Applause]
high school is not embarrassing yeah now
two years and 32 years
here's what's crazy like and
congratulations for you guys and for you
guys but like
you know the 32 years like
it's always amazing to me but what's
envious to me is at 32 years they
there's a level of honesty
that they can talk to each other with
like let me tell you something right now
they said something to each other on the
car ride over that would end your
[ __ ] relationship tonight
at some point this week one of them was
like i [ __ ] hate you and the other
one was like i don't give a [ __ ]
32 years nobody wants you either sit
down and shut the [ __ ] up where are you
going
you can't hurt each other's feelings
anymore you know that's that is over you
two but you know what else is great at
two years you guys still got hope
yeah that's right there's no hope at
that table
not unless i have a kid named hope
that's it you know
yeah but you know what else in two years
what i like two years you know you're
still kind of in discovery phase like do
you like it when i touch you there i
don't know
try it
do you like that move i don't know give
it a run big bar
32 years
you're not there's not a lot of
discovery i don't think
not unless it's like i think i got
something growing on my ass will you
take a look at it
[Laughter]
yo 32 years too like if you want to make
your partner orgasm after 32 years i
imagine
it's like having the xbox cheat code do
you know what i mean like are you ready
to come okay xxyyyyyyyyyyyyy
why is your right foot in the air you
know why shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
night
[Music]
[Music]